Can you create a folder structure for the project?
Yes.
You don't need to know anything about the framework in order to create the HTML
and CSS files that you'll later be writing.
Can you create a DOM tree for the page?
Yes.
Using the structure of the mock-up,
you could pretty much figure out what the DOM tree should look like.
Can you write HTML that defines the DOM?
Yes, you can.
If you can figure out the DOM tree for
the page, you can start writing the HTML that will create it.
Can you assign class names to HTML Elements?
No you can't.
Not until you have your frame work picked out.
Each frame work will have its own custom classes.
Can you write CSS?
Not quite.
Not until you pick a framework.
And can you test the page?
Well if you don't have the CSS you're not going to be able to test it yet.